this room so the first outcome of the
Eurogroup today is that the mission
shoes will return to Athens the second
one is that we stressed that really more
work needs to be done more effort needs
to be put in for that to be a good
outcome there are still physical gaps to
be filled and some of the reforms will
have to be deepened as you know we have
a long-standing promise that if Greek
Greek government fulfills its
commitments in the program and they live
as a primary surplus that we will do
what is necessary to make the depth
annual depth service manageable that
discussion is going to be on our table
in the near future many of the fiscal
financial structural reforms undertaken
have put Cyprus back on a path of a
sustainable growth and they are very
determined to hold on to that
accomplishment and to check all
remaining challenges as far as Greece is
concerned I'm very happy of the
agreement that has been found today
which will allow the mission Chiefs to
go back to Athens as soon as tomorrow so
that they can lead the discussions on
the review of the programme there are
important challenges that remain in
Cyprus and Cyprus will have to face
those challenges but always with the
European support but I think we can all
rejoice the success of this program and
clearly we can say that the separate
economy is reinforced the Commission
will continue to monitor the situation
closely in the context of the European
semester euro area member states will
submit the national reform programs and
stability programs by mid-april and this
will be followed by country specific
recommendations including budgetary
policy guidance in May the esm team will
go tomorrow to Athens and will continue
to work with the other institutions and
the creek on thorities authorities on
the review hopefully one can move
swiftly to complete the review
because the quiddity is getting tighter
Cyprus is the fourth success case after
Ireland Portugal and Spain despite the
fact that the last review was not
concluded but overall it's positive it's
also positive that we only had to
disperse seventy percent of Z committed
amount of nine billion euro Twitter's
pursed 6.3 billion